you probably read and seen a little bit
by now about Canada's new prime minister
Justin Trudeau he's charming he says all
the right things and he's anyone but
Stephen Harper but what is the guy with
that great head of hair the leader of
Canada's Liberal Party actually stand
for let's start on domestic issues
Justin Trudeau has promised a national
public inquiry into missing and murdered
Native women he wants to create more
jobs he wants to cut the taxes for the
middle class and increase them for
Canada's one percent and to really will
you he wants to legalize marijuana
recreational marijuana which will have
an inevitable impact on us drug policy
and Canadian environmentalists are
hoping that Trudeau and the Liberals
will reverse some of the environmental
damage done by climate change skeptics
Harper and the Conservatives while
Trudeau has pledged to increase funding
for the sciences and promoting clean
energy he supports the Keystone XL
pipeline
something the president of Canada's
biggest trade partner currently opposes
then there's foreign policy Trudeau
supports a Canadian military presence in
the Middle East but less than 24 hours
after being elected he called up
President Obama to let him know that
Kenneth combat mission in Iraq and Syria
against Isis was going to end Trudeau
also wants to re-establish relations
with Iran and will push for immediate
processing of 25,000 Syrian refugees
into Canada all of that sounds like a
lot but how much change can Trudeau
actually bring to everything that's
happened under the Harper government
after all Stephen Harper held office for
10 years longer than Justin Trudeau's
entire political career and the Liberal
Party doesn't exactly have the best
domestic track record either it's one
marred in scandal domestic
militarization and security policies
rooted in the so-called global war on
terror kind of like the u.s. Democrats
also while Trudeau based his entire
election campaign on a call for Canadian
unity condemning Harper's Islamophobic
campaign terror against the Scott
Canadian vigil
the Canadian he and many other liberals
supported divisive bills that were
characterized as either pandering to the
fear of immigrants or Canada's version
of the Patriot Act
so yes Stephen Harper is gone and so
many Canadians have let out a sigh of
relief but is the new guy going to
deliver
you